hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for
monday october 12th
uh 2020 what's going on how
are you sorry the podcast is so late
um i was traveling today and i had my
whole family with me so
uh couldn't sneak off in the morning to
try to knock it out so
my apologies to you um how are you how
was your weekend
you have a good time do you watch any
football did you watch any basketball
let me get it out of the way
congratulations to your los angeles
lakers 2020 nba champion
the the 17th nba championship
that they are now tied with the boston
celtics
and uh we better get moving are they
going to pass us but
um the heat put up a great fight
all heart on that team and
um you know but they just didn't have
enough firepower
they just the lakers just came in that
last game and they were just like i have
a dead i didn't see the game i was
working but
they were obviously like [ __ ] this we're
winning this and it just seemed like
everybody was on
i heard they were up by 30 at one point
um i imagine there was a lot of
champagne
was beginning to be drank by the in
probably towards the end of the third
quarter which
is always an exciting thing so um
good for them happy for their fans and
all that type of stuff all right
um moving on uh speaking of exciting
all right i got something exciting to
talk about how about
those cleveland browns huh
[Laughter]
how exciting are the [ __ ] cleveland
brown that's like they're like my
favorite team to watch right now because
they were such an exciting team when
there was brian sipping the cardiac kids
when i was a kid
and to watch now that they i guess they
got the new offense where they're
letting baker mayfield
baker uh roll out and watching
him you know getting on the same page
with odell beckham
it sucks that chubs got hurt but still
they still had seemed like they got they
got had another guy
i forget cause i watched him a few weeks
ago i think when they played the cowboys
i forget who they played this week jesus
christ
i watched a little i think i watched the
highlights of that
um obviously i had the big gig saturday
night so
i was out late or just up late i
couldn't sleep for two nights in a row i
was so [ __ ]
psyched um but um
let me check the nfl scores out here
shall we nfl scores here we go what do
we got what have we got
um ah [ __ ] i was taping that game god
damn [ __ ] [ __ ] chargers up 20 to
three on the saints
the [ __ ] is going on you know the
charges are doing all right is that that
that
herbert guy a bear whatever his name is
tyrod taylor gets his [ __ ] lung
punctured
by a trainer how the hell does that ever
happen he can't get his goddamn job back
cowboys beat the giants the [ __ ]
giants man
put up 34 points they still haven't won
um
tough times there um
but i heard uh what's his face what the
[ __ ] is their name
their quarterback's name dak or
something like that i heard he got hurt
that sucks
speaking of hurt the 49ers they're so
hurt they lost by almost [ __ ] 30
points to the goddamn
dolphins yeah the browns beat the colts
that's my [ __ ] team i like watching
the browns and i like watching the
seahawks it's so weird
now that tom brady has gone and so many
players have moved around i like now i
like like the seahawks it's weird i
loved the seahawks when i was a kid
jim zorn steve lodgett
david craig kurt warner
the original um
kenny easley was that his name
yeah the the big hitting uh defensive
back that they had our safety
um and i always loved the browns when i
was a kid the cardiac kids right brian
sipe and all of them and now they're
exciting to watch again
it's a lot of great football being
played out there
you know i wish the new england patriots
could quit sneezing on each other so
maybe we
we could play a few games um we keep
getting
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
with us where the hell are we
i i is it already week five is there
anything
faster than the nfl season bears beat
the buccaneers
um oh my god did you see what brady's
offensive line did to him on that one
drive holy [ __ ]
they got like three holding calls in a
row it was like second and 30-something
and then they go to run another play and
the long-haired ginger
on the team at the end of the play i
mean he barely head-butted the guy but
now they flag everything he headbutts
the guy
dude [ __ ] tom brady yelled at that
dude
it was so satisfying because you know
i'm i am the biggest buccaneers fan now
because they got brady and gronk and uh
i guess we're just gonna keep getting
covered so i don't know what the [ __ ]
we're doing this year i obviously root
for the patriots first but like
it's buccaneers second if we don't win
it i want to see tom get number seven
um the ravens looks like the first ones
to shut down joe burrow
and uh what else happened around the
league i did watch the fourth quarter
of your uh las vegas are you doing great
i watched that game that was a fun ass
game to watch even just i caught it in
the end
um and i heard an amazing stat
that this is only the third time in
patrick mahomes career he's lost by
uh more than seven points i mean jesus
christ if that guy isn't the next guy to
wear the crown
um i don't know who is i mean you're
basically always in the game
or blowing somebody out essentially or
winning by a little come on bill say all
the scenarios
um what else the steelers you're
pittsburgh steelers
4-0 5-0 what are they 4-0 5-0 i think
uh and then they say every time they get
to that level they've always won the
super bowl so we shall see
um what else happened around
the league oh tomorrow tomorrow the
bills play
i'm psyched to finally watch their uh
their quarterback there what the [ __ ]
his name
i don't know my head's spinning from the
weekend here so i can't remember
anybody's name here josh allen josh
allen that's right
you get to see you know
i guess the the next kings reclaiming
the afc east
which is amazing because they had it
before the patriots started dominating
there was the jets there for a minute
with bill
parcells and they jets also won once
with uh
with uh uh sexy toes there
the guy was in defeat rex ryan
um i don't know all right so
i can't believe i just saw that [ __ ]
score man it was like my evening here i
was gonna sit down and watch the goddamn
game whatever
it's still gonna be fun um so anyway
with that what else is there to talk
about
um let's just talk about snl for a
second i just
i just want to thank everybody over
there
um laura michaels and the entire cast
and everybody that works there i had the
most fun
i had so much goddamn fun doing that
show i thought i was gonna be an
absolute wreck
i'm not gonna lie to you i was a nervous
wreck
um on sunday afternoon
because i had run my monologue a couple
of times and it wasn't working
because i was putting it together and it
always that's
how it always goes but i had this big
legendary show that i'm gonna go do
and everybody knows the first episode
the first guest
host was george carlin so i was really
trying to downplay
the magnitude of the gig but
you can't when it's snl so i was kind of
in my head
and i was going on stage and rather than
just telling my jokes i was
asking the crowd if here's this idea
what how what about this one and they i
was just eating my balls
and then of course i was also doing
covid comedy so i was standing on
sidewalks and on top of roofs
and i was just like what the [ __ ] and i
went to the taping
saturday night uh when chris
rock did it and um
it really helped me as far as when i saw
it i was just like oh my god i can't
believe
this giant show is this whole the whole
history of this show
is in this little studio because it just
seems
because when you watch it on tv it is
just the biggest thing ever when you go
there
it's it's not it's a sound stage it's
just like this little thing
and so in a way that helped me to relax
but then on the other side like
the [ __ ] opening sketch had jim
carrey
and alec baldwin two of the greatest to
ever do it and i'm going
like i can't follow those guys i can't
i'm just
and i was like you got to hold it
together hold it together right
and by the way i had already run my set
like three times before i went over
there for the taping and just ate my
balls
so i was trying to play it cool and um
i i watched the whole show and i talked
to chris afterwards he gave me some
great advice and everything and i was
thinking in my head
i was like god i wish i was him right
now because he's done
and it went great i just i can't wait
for that
and i just started thinking about 101 am
you know sunday morning the following
week when the gig would be over which is
the the stupidest thing you can do
because now you're not going to enjoy it
and that's right where my head went i
started catastrophizing my head
i had a total [ __ ] panic attack in
the hotel room
the sunday you know right before i was
gonna go in on the monday the first day
and
my wife being the rock that she is she
she talked me down and all of that
and um you know i put her through some
[ __ ]
on some big gigs like that freaking out
which
really is normal when you're doing
something like that
but it's also sucks for the person
you're with that they have to sit there
it's like
you know somebody threatening to kill
themselves that isn't going to kill
themselves you know it gets exhausting
after a while
it's like you're not going to kill
yourself can you stop putting me through
this right
so um i just was like all right i don't
want to put my wife through this
and i don't want to be in this mindset
the whole week
because it's going to fly by and then
afterwards
i know i'm gonna do well i know i'm
gonna have a good time and then i'm
gonna look back going i wish i enjoyed
this
so i just took all of my angst and said
there's no reason to be nervous the
whole week
until 11 30 saturday night and then if
you want to be a little nervous
manageably nervous whatever and then the
show's gonna start and just once i get
out on stage
i'll be fine so uh i just
every day i'd wake up and i'd be like oh
my god i'm doing snl
and i'd be like it's monday we just sit
down we hang out but
we kick around some ideas blah blah blah
blah nobody's going to see it none of
this is going to be taped
you could literally do a face plant you
know
into a pie nobody's gonna see it and
then i just kept doing that every
morning
and i ended up having the best time
and um being obviously
any comedian a huge fan of the show the
greatest
one of the greatest parts about the show
is not only that you you get to do it is
you get to see
how they put it together you get to see
how hard everybody works
because that's the thing when you host
the show you know everybody around you
is busting their ass and you're just
they're just
waltzing you around like the friggin
prom queen
everybody's writing [ __ ] for you what's
your wheelhouse everybody is
they're all busting their ass
and then people are you okay is
everything okay with you it's like yeah
i'm not doing [ __ ] you guys
you guys are all working and um
i just you know you sit down you do the
table read you read like a zillion
sketches and um
i was reading them you know and i
thought there was going to be like
you know a lot that weren't going to be
good and i was reading them like these
are all
[ __ ] funny and even the ones that
aren't as funny as the other one you
could see how you could
punch this up by saturday it was going
to work so i started
really getting excited like man these
guys these writers are amazing right
then we did the table read the table
read was fun as [ __ ]
and i got to see the whole cast and
um watching them how they do it and
it's the whole thing was just i don't
know it was it was incredible then we
started rehearsing them
and you get to go up in the room as they
start putting together this which ones
after the table read which ones they're
gonna pick
and then you go into the war room and
we're thinking of doing this here and
that there
what do you think about a pre-tape here
and you get to sit in on all of it
and then there's all this memorabilia
and [ __ ] like i took a picture there was
a flyer in there from the first show
that had george carlin you know
george carlin's picture on it said
something like a new show
saturday night live or something like
that and
um and then friday we did the pre-tapes
and i had a great time doing that we
rehearsed and then i went back out shot
some more stuff that was a long that was
the only long day
and then saturday you just show up they
they do like a dress rehearsal and then
they do one in front of the crowd
and then you just do the show and
it just flies by is the only thing i can
tell you
and um standing backstage
when they were doing you know after they
did the uh
the cold open with jim carrey and maya
rudolph
dude my head spinning i forgot the whole
jack white part
you know the poor guy who was gonna do
the show
was doing what i would be doing if i was
a rockstar at 27. he was making out with
some pretty girl and somebody saw it and
took a picture whatever
whatever whatever you know who doesn't
do that at 27 or 28 they'll have them on
just not this show so then they added
jack white and then jack white came in
like the show wasn't already exciting
enough he comes in
and um i got to watch them
rehearse and i got to tell you something
man this is
amazing as it is to watch
when you guys watched it at home to be
standing right there when they were
doing it like when i tell you
all the hair on my arm was standing up
when these guys started playing
and the drummer was it is it daru jones
or daru jones i didn't i
might i like the week just flew by his
[ __ ]
setup my buddy said it look he was
playing drums looks like he's
gonna be like falling out a window and
um they just came in
and just [ __ ] ripped
just face melting [ __ ] and i was like
holy [ __ ] and i just started thinking
you know
if i crush my monologue and i just do my
part in these sketches
and then jack's gonna do that twice this
is gonna be a [ __ ] killer show
and then when we did the dress rehearsal
there was all there was so much [ __ ] in
there for eddie van halen by the way
um like i didn't know that they were
gonna show um
the clip from when he came on i think it
was in 89 when his then wife valerie
bertinelli hosted the show
so they had that clip and we did the
dress rehearsal in front of the crowd
and we were about ready to say goodnight
um they played that clip and i didn't
know it was coming
and i like the emotion of that was just
like [ __ ]
like what are the odds like
you know that i could get to say goodbye
to this guy
on this stage man was crazy so
and then the other thing was jack was
telling me that you know
for the longest time i've ever seen like
jack jack white is literally a guy who
could have gone to sears roebuck and
bought a [ __ ] guitar
and he'll make it sound better than you
know someone like me on a
ten thousand dollar guitar he just can
get that sound he's just
like i can't even describe like his
whole vibe it's like he he's like a time
traveler it's like he's from now but he
if you also feel like you're talking to
somebody from the 1930s in like the best
way
and he goes on stage and it's like he's
like [ __ ] possessed
and i got such i got so much out of
watching him
even in the rehearsal where it reminded
me of a story i remember here
chris laden leighton uh steve ray
vaughan's drummer was talking about
where stevie was talking about some
guitar lick and they were on the tour
bus
and when he played it he's he still
played it like he was in front of 30 000
people
he didn't half-ass it like he had a
musical idea and he just [ __ ]
just you know only knew one way to do it
like jack white and his band had that
vibe
and i don't know why but i always grab
it i think
just because i've always loved music i
i learn so much as a comic watching
musicians if that makes any [ __ ]
sense it was like i was telling you when
i watched that herbie hancock thing
he told that story about uh miles davis
going don't play the
the butter notes or whatever and i was
like i know what that means comedically
that means go on stage and say what the
[ __ ] you want to say
don't ask the crowd if it's funny tell
them it's funny and they don't like it
[ __ ] them that's what it is and
also take risks get outside your comfort
zone all of that i and i
i don't know why um maybe just because
i've watched so much stand up after a
while you just sort of like get a little
numb to it that i have to see
i have to learn stand-up lessons through
musicians it's really weird
so um
anyway uh
i don't know where the [ __ ] i am so we
go out to go do the show and i gotta
tell you when you're standing back there
like ready to go on man it is just like
you know i don't even know i there's
there's no way to describe it it just
you know what i kept doing i kept
standing on that stage whenever i could
because i was looking at it getting
butterflies i was like i need to keep
standing up here
talking to cameramen and [ __ ] while i'm
on this stage i have to get comfortable
here
or this isn't going to work and i kept
doing that and of course i'm a big fan
of sean pelton the drummer there
i got to meet him he was such a nice guy
he gave me a drumstick which is [ __ ]
awesome
so um you know
he was a nice guy and i talked to him
got to know him a little bit so when i
came out to do the monologue
i looked at him and he was having a good
time big smile really helped me out so
thanks to him
and um and then now i have to give a
shout out to lauren
and just everybody over there and then
all of these amazing
comedic actors that uh what do you call
i think that's the right word comedic
actors uh
beck bennett michael j p davidson of
course
uh mikey day heidi gadner
uh she was [ __ ] hilarious she wrote
these two killer sketches that didn't
quite make the show i hope they do them
in the future because they were great
colin jose
kate mckinnon who was the king over
there she's just [ __ ]
i was watching her and i'm literally
like all this all she needs to get
somebody just has to write her just give
her the oscar part and she's going to go
get it she was
like like i learned so much from her
um alex moffat kyle mooney had a great
time with those guys
you know back in pete and mikey day we
got to do the uh
the politically correct you know dawn
paulie all of that we had such a good
time
uh where else who else who else
uh oh aego chris redd
they wrote me some great stuff uh keenan
thompson
um was just amazing
calming force to be around and he's
[ __ ] hilarious
he's just a [ __ ] great dude uh
punky johnson you know last time i saw
her we were [ __ ] hanging out at the
uh and she's amazing she was like you
know everybody's favorite down at the
comedy store and she also worked at the
comedy store so she'd be like behind the
bar
you know getting drinks for the crowd
and then going up on stage crushing it
you know the typical you know comic
coming up and i i can't tell you how
happy
everybody was at the comedy store when
she got um
snl it was like the same thing like when
uh
melissa visagno got it uh bo and yang i
got to know him
it just they were just all of them were
so they were so great and so generous in
all of the sketches that like
it basically once you do the monologue
you can then just sort of
hide in their talent you know and just
deliver your lines oh jesus
me trying to [ __ ] read out loud and
trying to get the hang of it's the top
card
because they lift it up and then you can
see the bottom card don't read that [ __ ]
until until they put it up there because
i kept stepping on people's lines
um but like i said i just want to thank
everybody over there for uh
get me through it and lauren gave me
like the perfect advice
um for my monologue
after dress rehearsal he said just make
sure you take
the time to tell people thank you and
that you're because i was kind of just
jumping into my set a little too quickly
you know because i want to go get to the
first joke get to the first laugh
rookie moves but i mean you revert back
to your
rookie mistakes when you you get into
something that's as big as that but
um my overall takeaway from that show
was it was it's the most
exciting fun gig i've ever done
since i got into show business i still
can't believe that i got to do it i
still can't believe it went that well
and um i just can't believe how much fun
it was because i was
like i was so [ __ ] nervous when you
know i was initially supposed to do it
in april and then the covid thing
happened and i'm not gonna lie to you
like
i think i was more excited that i got
canceled than i was bummed because i was
definitely bummed out
but i was also like oh thank god that
[ __ ]
that you know the the the the countdown
to having to [ __ ]
have my [ __ ] together to pull that off
has been shut off
and um
you know i don't know the whole thing
but the whole thing worked out because
of everybody over there at the show so
fooled them again got away with it um
and i also got to thank
the comedy seller stand up new york and
new york comedy club
uh for all the stage time you guys gave
me that week get
ready to do it and uh also
for keith robinson for heckling me while
i was doing my monologue
having no respect for the fact that i
had this level of a
high pressure gig and it just put me in
a stupid mood
like keith has like this
sage thing about him he probably saw
that i was a little tight or he was just
being his usual [ __ ] self
like i don't give a [ __ ] that you're
doing your monologue stupid
i don't like your jokes so um
it was uh yeah that was a hell of an
experience i'll never forget it and then
the
after it it um
after it was over you know
you're standing on that stage realizing
how it goes by so goddamn fast
i know at one point when i was changing
when i saw
a picture of me with the snl thing and
the band was playing
i got such a as i that's when it really
hit me was like i can't like this is
real like i'm on this [ __ ] show
it was nuts and um then in the end you
get to say good night
i got to say rest in peace eddie van
halen they got me a van halen t-shirt
and oh also jack white i forgot he was
those the subtle nods to eddie was
i didn't even finish the story about
jack how he used to just play like these
little store-bought
he used to make guitars and stuff for
himself like i don't even know
but he uh he had the eddie van halen
wolfgang
model which was the name of uh
eddie's son and that's eddie's company
he named the guitar after his son
because he's the greatest dad ever right
um not only the greatest guitarist great
i mean if you do that for your kid you
know you're all in right
so and jack was showing me like the
whole setup of it and everything
and um
you know no one's gonna go on stage and
play a van halen song
because you're not gonna do it like
eddie
but there was one point where the song
where they brought it down and just for
the perfect amount six to eight seconds
10 seconds or whatever
jack did a little tap on solo just this
totally
coolest little tip of the cap to eddie
and then went right back in
to and now this is how i do it
and um and then they showed that video
and then i got to wear the van halen
t-shirt say eddie rest in peace i just
thought
you know when a guy like that of that
magnitude
passes that a show that legendary to
give him
his due it was so humbling to be a part
of that
so yeah
crazy crazy crazy crazy so with that
there you go um let's see here let's
read some advertising here all right
what do we got we got simply safe
everybody simply safe okay here's the
thing about home security companies most
trappy with high prices
tricky contracts and lousy customer
support
uh so while there are a lot of options
out there there's only one no-brainer
simply safe
simply safe's got everything you need to
protect your home with none of the
drawbacks of traditional home security
it's got an arsenal of sensors and
cameras to blanket every room
window and door tailored specifically
for your home
professional monitoring keeps watch day
and night
ready to send police fire or medical
professional
professionals if there's an emergency uh
you can set it up yourself in under an
hour uh just peel and stick the sensors
exactly where you need them no
technician required and there's no
contract no pushy sales guys no hidden
fees no fine print all this starts
at 15 a month i'm not the only one who
thinks simply safe is great
uh us news and world report named it the
best overall home security of 2020.
try simply save today at
simplysafeburr.com
you get a free hd security camera
there's nothing to lose that's simply
safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
bur b-u-r-r dot-com all right look who
it is everybody oh
my bookie how you doing how the [ __ ] are
you
hang on here take a sip there uh between
the nfl
college ball and mlb playoffs playoffs
uh there's no shortage of sports to
watch or to put your money on
and with the way the last presidential
debate went it won't be long before my
book he has
odds on donald trump to join the wwe
uh whether you're tuned in or not i hope
you guys
uh cashed in on some of those debate
prop bets that went up
what you can actually bet on the debate
because there were several that could
have been considered free money trump to
mention
russia that was a lock you can bet on
the [ __ ] debate
anyway and that's the best part about
betting at my bookie they offer great
values
in their odd and lines you shouldn't
tell that [ __ ] trump and biden will
will they're gonna cash in on that have
somebody else bet for him
if this is real um they offer great
value in their odds and lines whether
you're betting on the nfl action or
crazy prop bets there's always a little
money for everyone
and always always always cash to be one
oh sam j i gotta give sam jay a shout
out
too from snl uh i've been playing in
the my bookie super contest this season
and i hope you guys are too
but it's only a ten dollar entry for the
chance to win a share of a hundred
thousand dollars in cash prizes
for a ten dollar investment um i don't
think you can bet
what what for a ten dollar investment
i don't think you can beat that sorry i
ready to bet ten bucks
sign me up twice can i do that probably
not another good investment to make
would be uh to fade the atlanta falcons
for the rest of the year if they blow
another lead late
uh whatever you do if you're going to
bet this season bet my
but it my bookie and use my promo code
burr to grab yourself
a deposit match uh when you join because
who doesn't like
free money on top of their deposit
that's promo code burr burr to claim
your bonus at my bookie
all right what's next um manscaped
everybody
all right listen up fellas are you hairy
down there
huh can you even see your junk anymore
you know if you can't see it why is she
gonna want to touch it huh
you know you'll need a goddamn spider
the [ __ ] big hogan hanging out all
right let's let's move on okay listen up
fellas because today
we have a new manscape product alert
manscape just released the weed
whacker nose and ear hair trimmer
i gotta get one of these things take a
look in the mirror and i guarantee
you'll see hair sticking out of those
holes it's time to keep your ear and
nose hair
looking as nice as your clean shaven
pubes yeah cause i'll tell you right now
if you've got [ __ ] coming out of your
ears and your nose
nobody's listening to what the [ __ ]
you're saying all right your sales pitch
is out the window manscape is forever
changing the grooming
game with their weed whacker uh this
nose and ear hair trimmer provides
proprietary skin safe technology which
helps
which helps prevent nicks snags and tugs
in those delicate holes
uh the premium landscape weed whacker
uses a 9000 rpm
motor powered 360 degree rotary dual
blade system
it its intelligently contoured design
enhanced the trimming experience and it
is waterproof
which makes it easy oper makes for easy
operation and cleaning
the only nose hairs trimmer on the
market
with a powerful and rechargeable lithium
ion battery that lasts
up to 90 minutes of use have you ever
pulled your nose hair out with your
fingers
i've done that that might hurt worse
than nicking your balls
you know what i'll tell you what the
nose hair makes your eyes water more
you know your balls just makes you
crumple to your knees
uh manscapes is whacking your weeds a
time
makes whacking your weeds a time to look
forward to delivering maximum con
confidence while providing hygiene yes
you will get a replaceable blade every
three months to keep your weed whacking
time clean and enjoyable look fellas 79
percent of
partners polled admitted that long nose
hair is a major turn off
it's time to upgrade your manscape
routine with the weed whacker get 20
off plus free shipping with the code bur
20 at manscape.com
thank you manscape for keeping our pubes
trimmed and the hairs in our holes
looking nice get twenty percent off free
shipping
with the code burr burr at manscape.com
that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the promo code bird20
what are you waiting for go whack your
weeds
all right what's next stamps.com
everybody holy [ __ ] stamps.com
uh the holiday season dooby dooby doo
it's coming right up i'm gonna make
something pumpkin bread
cause the rest of my year is easy um the
holiday season more people will be
mailing stuff than ever before that
means the post office is going to be
busy you don't got time for that [ __ ]
stamps.com brings the post office right
to you and now ups shipping right into
your computer
mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home and office with
with stamps.com anything you can do with
post office you can do with just a few
clicks all right you've heard me talk
about stamps.com they've been sponsoring
the show
for almost seven and a half years now
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices an online seller
fulfilling orders during the
record-setting holiday season or even a
giant warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
with stamps.com you get five cents off
every first class stamp
and up to forty percent off uh priority
mail and up to 62 percent off ups
shipping rates stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder over 900
000 small businesses already use
stamps.com
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season uh at the post office this year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk
uh with my promo code uh burr burr
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus free shipping and a
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that's stamps.com enter
bur stamps.com
never go to the post office again
all right okay to the podcast here
all right modern scam all right so last
uh last episode last podcast i think i
was talking to you
about scams out there to look out for
right
well here we go here's some more modern
scams if you guys know scams that are
out there please give everybody the
heads up i love this modern scam
hey billy baldbrains i heard you were
talking about scams old and new
on the october 5th podcast and i wanted
to tell you about a new scam that people
are doing these days
all right i was on the dating app hinge
there's a dating app called hinge all i
can think of is unhinged is that where
all the psychos go
anyways uh hinge and saw a hooker on
there
her profile said who wants to [ __ ]
dm me for rates on snapchat
oh boy oh is this the cops so i did just
that
it was 200 bucks for three hours so i
thought about it for a few weeks and
then went ahead to book her
she asked for a half hour up front so i
sent her a hundred right
then oh no then she put me in touch with
her boss who asked for 300
refundable deposit for the girl's
booking code
it was supposed to be sent back to me
after the d
after the deed so i sent it like an
idiot
then she asked for a 625 deposit to
guarantee
safety which i also sent like a dumb ass
too at this point they're just going to
keep going
so i sent that like the dumbass am then
she asks for 925
sh she will be safe in your arms
i finally realized it was a scam and i
was out 1025 bucks
[ __ ] me so for all your followers listen
listeners who suck at hitting on chicks
watch out for those scams oh
dude don't [ __ ] hookers man don't [ __ ]
hookers that's
never the answer all right
it you're gonna feel like [ __ ]
afterwards and then that's somebody's
daughter who didn't raise her
all right the whole thing is t you don't
want to be a part of that world anyway
also if anyone knows
how to find people based on their
zeal z-e-l-l-e zelly
or venmo accounts please let me know
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all right
well thanks for letting people know
about that [ __ ]
uh yeah don't ever [ __ ]
don't ever dm money to a hooker she
ain't showing up
um you and video games all right
dear billy bullshitter first of all
let me say [ __ ] you all right fair
enough and then go
[ __ ] yourself i had recently considered
writing in and talking [ __ ] to you
about your thoughts on video games
did i ever say they were did i say they
were i mean i probably did i was just
saying i can't handle them i'm going to
lose
my life they're too good now
with your virtual reality thing you can
talk to other people you don't have to
leave your [ __ ] house i can't deal
with that
all right but maybe i maybe i shouldn't
video game people i have no idea i have
a tendency to piss people off if you
haven't noticed
all right let's see here what do we got
here um
where the hell was i on this okay
because i was listening to one of your
older podcasts where you were flapping
your gums about it
video games but decided not to however
you've once again
sullied one of my hobbies and i can no
longer stand
for this sir all right i like it he's
slapping me with the white glove okay
let me have it here we go
video games are a perfectly normal
pastime
just because you struggle with
technology as much as i struggle with
finding
the [ __ ] does not make it
a childish thing to do oh that's what i
said yeah yeah you're playing video
games
it is kind of silly i i stand by that
it is kind of silly past a certain age
to be playing video games
um i don't know
it's maybe uh maybe i'm not progressive
um anyway am i over here flipping you
[ __ ] because you like to bang around on
your little drum set
like you're getting ready for the school
talent show oh look at you
um i would actually argue that i'm
actually learning how to play drums it's
good for my
uh you know it's a that's a it's an
actual skill
sir i will say that as opposed to
sitting there clicking your [ __ ]
i mean i guess playing asteroids is is
also a skill
all right this isn't fair to him if i'm
gonna trash him the whole i'm gonna let
him get all this [ __ ] out i'm not gonna
go trump here and interrupt him so let
me read this again
am i here flipping you [ __ ] because you
like to bang around in your little drum
set
like you're getting ready for the school
talent show no
while i may not sink all of my time into
playing games i still enjoy playing them
for several hours
on end if i have the time i go to work
every day
i got my college degree i pay my taxes
oh this is the indignant [ __ ] i do
everything i'm supposed to do and i
think everyone else
that's doing what they're supposed to do
and still likes playing video games
uh gets a pass if i had to guess
you probably picture a gamer as some
greasy fat 40 year old
pimpled loser that eats bagel bites
drinks mountain dew
code red and plays games all day long
um uh not a hundred percent no i just
i mean all my friends who play video
games aren't like that i don't think
anyway yes those people need to grow up
but
not us industrious hard-working people
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not an ex i'm not an expert on the
topic and in no way qualified to have a
say in this matter
but that's never stopped no one from
giving her given one all right
to be fair uh i'm only 26 year old i'm
only a 26 year old dope
so i can't predict whether or not i'll
still enjoy playing games from 10 years
from now
but i have to strike while the iron is
hot and stick up for people
because out of my own arrogance i'm
somehow that important
um dude you're crushing with the
self-deprecation because now i can't
trash your back that's tremendous
why don't you just find your own
business why don't you just mind your
own business over there
on that dumb elliptical of yours with
the rest of your goofy
the goofy people from the middle ages
and we'll mind our own business
over here playing make believe in some
virtual fantasy land deal
no go [ __ ] yourself i'm a comedian i'll
continue to make fun of you stop
acting like some [ __ ] hurt little
snowflake here i don't like video games
you know what that's one more
playstation available for you to go play
i will make fun of [ __ ] anything i
want to make fun of but i respect that
just
you know as long as you're living a life
i don't care if you're not living a life
i don't give you some greasy fat [ __ ]
who still lives at home with your
parents
i think it's funny past a certain age
to sit there playing a video game where
you're pretending to go to war
it's just funny to me i don't know why i
think it's funny but i also get up upset
about sports and [ __ ]
which i also know is absolutely uh
is absolutely ridiculous but um the real
thing is though i
i quit playing video games
i was uh older than this 26 year old guy
i was like in my early 30s and i was
playing
um grand theft auto 3 and siphon filter
2.
and they were so [ __ ] amazing
and i was nowhere in this business
and rather than working on jokes and
[ __ ] like that i was sitting there maybe
just being a stand-up comic where you
have the whole day off
where you can either write a screenplay
or play [ __ ] eight hours of uh going
on
vigilante like shooting sprees
um medal of honor was another one
listen i'm like i love video games
the same way i love booze but i couldn't
handle either one of them so god bless
you if you can dip in for a couple of
[ __ ] hours but i got kids i can't
[ __ ] do it so
but i do there is something funny to me
about somebody in their 40s
playing grand theft auto 58 i mean there
is
it's it's it's funny sorry the same way
you picture me downstairs
playing drums in my garage that's funny
right it's [ __ ] you know so you
make fun of me you can still make fun of
me for that because i'm not going to
stop making fun of [ __ ] people that
play video games it's just [ __ ] past a
certain age it's just funny to me
all right uh gmc motorhome
originally owned by nfl films what the
[ __ ]
i heard you were looking for one of
these i've got over 10 000 invested
needs work want a good home for it if
interested let me know gives me the
phone number
i'm too old and broke to fix it
i know you can do it justice make an
offer
there was some sort of link here oh i
didn't get any of the pictures oh maybe
you know something
hang on a second let me look at this let
me look at this thing
here's a great thing to try to sell to
my wife hey honey you know how we never
go camping or anything
you know that right you know this i'm
doing the
sketch from saturday night live um where
is it live
reads mm content
modern scam video games all right i
don't have the link
to look at it sir or ma'am i'll have to
check that out
uh owned by nfl films
that's amazing does it have the nfl logo
somewhere on it
sewn into the uh vinyl seats
all right anyways let's plow ahead
virgin boyfriend okay here we go
virgin boyfriend over there uh dearest
bill
uh you're a [ __ ] legend oh thank you
i don't think that's true but thank you
anyways
anyways i'm an 18 year old lady
i love hearing from the ladies and i've
been dating my 19 year old boyfriend for
the past seven months for the most part
the relationship is all fine
and danny except for one key factor
there is no sex
he's a virgin and constantly says he
doesn't feel ready
i of course want to respect this but
it's been seven
months before dating him i was
relatively promiscuous
and was is
i guess having sex far more regularly
than this i have no shame in saying i
enjoy sex nor should you
don't let [ __ ] people you know the
church or guys or any of that [ __ ] that
go out and have your fun be safe as long
as you're having a good time
um hence this is kind of a dilemma i
find myself in now
this sounds grossly narcissistic
uh but it's quite evident i'm way out of
his league
no maybe you just know your value i mean
you've been waiting around seven months
what the [ __ ]
um i i okay i got some opinions on this
let me finish this
i constantly have guys throwing
themselves at me and it's going to be
hard to resist not hooking up with these
fine men when i'm being deprived of a
sexual relationship with my boyfriend
i'd feel horrible of giving him an
ultimatum of sex or we break up
but i don't know what else to do please
enlighten me with your grown man wisdom
uh go consensually [ __ ] yourself
um i think you need to find out why
um there's a number of different roads
this could go
okay uh he could have been molested
um he could have had some religious
upbringing that shamed him he could be
gay there's a bunch of things but i
think you need to clear the air
and he needs to start actively talking
about
other than you're just saying i'm not
ready yet
um he's not even kissing you like he
needs to
you know if he's gonna keep you he needs
to start actively
communicating with you maybe talking to
somebody and figure out what is
what's going on with him and then you
all you have to do
is see what your feelings are for this
person do you want to hang around
and let you know for this person to undo
whatever the [ __ ] their problem is
because
you know the reality is is when you're
single and you're trying to find out who
you're supposed to be with
you're 18 years old i don't know you're
going to marry this guy like i don't you
got to be selfish
in a way but i mean but you also
shouldn't be hurting people
you know um i would try to help this
person
um as far as like try to get them to
open up
and give them some avenues to open up
and as they open up it's only fair that
you open up
and you don't have to you don't have to
do the ultimatum but you just have to
say hey i got needs to
and i'm attracted to you and i would
like to get on with this i don't
say it that quickly but you know what i
mean in a nice way but
um you shouldn't feel bad about any of
the feelings that you're having
um and he shouldn't feel ashamed of what
he's feeling about you guys just need to
talk about it
and you need to set some sort of game
plan that you can both live with
to try to move it ahead and
if you guys can find a game plan that
works for both of you you'll stay
together if you don't good luck to him
there's no reason to be a jerk
you know and just move on or work
through it that's basically it but
everything
you're feeling is valid everything that
that person's feeling is valid
people's feelings are valid even if they
don't agree with your feelings so
you guys get all your feelings out on
the table you look at all the cards you
try to figure it out
if you can you do if you can't you don't
but there's no hard feelings
right that's the most adult way to do it
so good luck with that and um
yeah you seem like a really cool person
um all right here we go
okay re-dumb work experiences okay we
got we got a little trend going
here we go dumb experiences dear billy
no booze
um i own a small boutique liquor store
in denver
i have a terrific loyal customer base
but every now and then
i get guests that are not used to our
style of
shop uh you can see it in their face
i swear to god i literally i don't know
why i was just thinking of this sketch
that i wanted
that i thought was like not every sketch
makes the show and i was just thinking
uh how that would have played out sorry
let me go back so i can actually pay
attention
i own a small boutique liquor store in
denver i have a terrific loyal customer
base
but every now and then i get guests that
are not used to our style of shop
you can see it in the face the moment
they walk in they are expecting a
regular old package
liquor store uh oh that's a great name
that's what that's what they called it
back when i was a kid
going down to the [ __ ] um it's a
beautiful shop with 600 different craft
beers 200 wines
70 bourbons etc etc yeah this is for
like
uh connoisseurs of alcohol and
somebody's coming in what trying to buy
a 12 a [ __ ] bud light kit
uh here i am here oh here are my
dumbfounded encounters i have had in the
three years since i bought the shop
i think that would be such a cool thing
to own a little boutique liquor store
that has all this high-end booze
i always thought that that would be
[ __ ] cool um
number one just a couple weeks ago a
woman about 50
years old or so came in and said i was
sent here to buy some blow
i responded i'm sorry what was that
she put her fingers to her mouth as if
she was going to smoke a cigarette
i said do you mean weed she had a tepid
look on her face like i was her parent
and quietly said
yes uh ma'am there was a dispensary at
the end of the block
and don't ask them for blow just tell
them you need some weed
oh that's hilarious that's clearly not a
drug user
was sent there by somebody who's maybe
too [ __ ] up
oh boutique liquor story here's another
dumb question oh this is right top five
stupid questions
this is this is what the segment is the
top five if you work for the public
um deal with the public in your job the
top five dumb questions
i threw myself under the bus for the
park ranger out
in uh joshua tree i went out to joshua
tree and asked a park ranger
where is the joshua tree um
don't ask him that there's a bunch of
that's like being in massachusetts
saying
where is the oak tree um
okay number two do you sell scotch tape
number three do you have any whiskey uh
i have an entire wall of whiskey it's
the first thing you see
when you walk in the door um number four
is this a real store i will never forget
this question
that's probably somebody just always
goes to costco uh number five are you
here i get this question at least once a
week it blows me away every time i'm
standing here
my door is open unless you know
something i don't i am here
um what do they can't see you is that
what they do or they
i don't know anyway all the best to you
and nia and the little ones
uh we'll see you at the comedy works
next time
you are around oh that's cool
i love a high-end liquor store i used to
i still love them
that's the [ __ ] best all right girl
calls me fat but she gained twice as
much weight
oh wow hey billy barratta had i had some
burrata yep
you can call me jordan all right me and
my girlfriend no kids
have been together for 11 years i am
six two and she is five seven when we
started started dating we were still
teenagers
and i was about 175 pounds and she was
about 115.
i am now 220 pounds and she is 200.
uh lately she is saying that i am
getting fat
220 pounds is not light but i am still
pretty okay for a guy
that is six too and people never think
i'm over 200 pounds
yeah but still dude you can't walk
around with that kind of weight that
that really hastens
how long you're gonna live belly fat um
i have a bit of a beer belly and i love
eating steak when she told me i'm
getting fat
i said quote i know i gained some weight
we both did maybe we should go out more
like we used to
she right away said oh so you think i'm
fat yeah
she said a little bear trap for you
because she's not happy with what she
looks like
i mean she almost doubled her [ __ ]
weight i'm superimposing me because i
know
how much i how much i beat myself up
um anyways i told her no and then i find
her sexy and love her
she said that i gained more than her
than she ever did
and i should eat healthier oh my god
yeah see what she's projecting here
she's
basically saying a bunch of [ __ ] to you
and then you can't say any [ __ ] back to
her
oh so you think i'm fat you should have
been like you just said that i'm fat
you just said i'm getting fat
you know you think i'm fat yeah you're
fat i'm fat we're fat we need to do
something about this [ __ ]
anyway i told her no i didn't find you
know i think she's sexy and i love her
uh she said
that i gained more with dude all right
if you're gonna marry her and have kids
if she's already like [ __ ] 50 pounds
overweight
she's really there's a lot of health
risks to that i i believe
uh she said that i gained more than she
ever did
and i should eat healthier this is
coming from someone who prefers
mcdonald's over a steakhouse
yeah she's in it she has the addiction
right now
is when you eat this [ __ ] food that
they have in this country
um the same way a drug addict doesn't
want to do drugs
the sickness just takes over you can
literally get that sickness
craving sugar and salt and bad food
speaking of that did you see
ireland subway uh
subway sandwiches that [ __ ] in
ireland
they are saying they are not legally
allowing subway to say
that their bread is bread because
there's so much sugar in it it's not
bread anymore
and you watch these [ __ ] [ __ ] at
subway rather than stop
serving that [ __ ] sugary [ __ ]
they're gonna go after politicians and
line their [ __ ] pockets
so they can still call it bread it's
[ __ ] unbelievable
unbelievable um
but it's funny they'd have more chances
of getting in trouble if they told jokes
anyways i said um i said knowing the
numbers i think you gained a little
more but that's fine like i said you are
sexy
and i want you and love you you said
that after you said the other [ __ ] i'm
sure she wasn't happy with that
maybe we should just both go out more
and have more fun if you know what i
mean
since then our sex life dropped to an
all-time low and i feel like she doesn't
feel attracted to me anymore
also weight has never been an issue
before since then i lost about 15 pounds
good man
she didn't even notice or won't say
anything about it at least yeah she
might be feeling bad about herself
and she's taking it out on you it seems
she's still
gaining weight it's starting to hang
around her belly and hips
whether i try to talk to her about it
talk to her about my feelings
or our sex life she gets really
defensive and mad
and i don't know what to do about it
anymore i love this woman to death and
just want to
to be happy together fat or not although
i prefer
at least to be healthy uh what would
billy bald balls do
please help thank you and go [ __ ]
yourself
um i would just say to her
just tell her you need to talk and i
would sit down
and tell her that you love her
and that you want to be with her but you
know like any relationship
there comes times we have to sit down
and talk and this is one of them
and i would just tell her how you're
feeling and just tell her what you want
to do and how it makes you feel when
the sex life it's like you told me that
i was getting fat
and then we had that conversation and
now you're not having sex with me i feel
like you're not attracted to me anymore
is that the truth is that the case i
would say
and then listen to what she says and
um then you just basically
have to tell her what you would like the
two of you to do which is to live a more
healthy lifestyle
i want to live a more healthy lifestyle
with you
and
[Music]
see what she says and just tell her how
you're feeling and tell her what you
want and what you want the two of you to
do
and leave it at that and if she gets
upset she cries and do all of that type
of stuff
just remain calm see i'm not trying to
hurt you i'm not insulting you i just
wanna i just feel like we need to
communicate here
i feel like there's something going on
i'm open to all options
and see how that goes and if she um
i i really think
that she sort of just i don't think
she's happy
with herself and i don't think it's you
i think it's her
and um
[Music]
you know that's it's a hard [ __ ] road
when you're on a road you don't want to
be on and you don't know how to get off
of it
it makes you hate yourself and then
you're ashamed of yourself
and then the walls come up and then you
kept you can lash out at people and
stuff like that
see i i think it's going to be more than
one conversation to try and get through
this so you're gonna have to be really
patient this is a tough one this is
probably one of the toughest ones
if the woman in life is putting on
weight and you know she's not happy
about it and she's being super [ __ ]
defensive
i mean that's literally like there's a
wild animal
i saw this one there was a [ __ ]
mountain lion stuck in a bear trap and
these guys were trying to free it
while this thing was trying to [ __ ]
defend itself it was
it's like i'm trying to help you and the
mountain lion didn't understand it
is essentially what you're dealing with
here
and i think women deal with it
you know for guys like you know you
can't get it up or something like that
that's going to cause a guy to start
doing the [ __ ] mountain lion
in the bear trap [ __ ] thing so um
yeah dude just know you got your work
cut out for you here it's going to be
more than one
conversation and then also know that
your feelings are valid and you
express them and she should hear them
and she should not be
what she's doing she shouldn't be doing
to you that's not fair to you all right
and uh she's hurting herself by
continuing to gain weight it's just it's
not going to be you can eat your way
into being a diabetic and
that whole [ __ ] nightmare or you can
just turn the ship around now
while you're young and and you know
it's a great thing to do like uh me and
my wife just started getting back into
like
working out together which is [ __ ]
awesome basically going for walks and
once you have kids you know it's hard
you don't have a lot of time but it's a
it's a great bonding thing like all
right let's do this and
she pushes me i push her or whatever and
it's it's a fun it can be a real fun
thing to do you just gotta
you know try and sell them on it that's
all
um so anyways all right uh okay that's
the podcast
um what a weekend uh thank you guys
i didn't thank you guys my head spinning
so much thank you guys for tuning in
watching
i i stayed offline because
i i need to just stay level you know
what i mean i can't
be reading a bunch of good [ __ ] i can't
be reading a bunch of negative [ __ ]
i did what i did some people like it
some people don't
you know there's a million comics out
there if
you like it keep watching me if you
don't like it don't don't watch me i
understand no big deal
so um i haven't but i just really
appreciate like all the emails that i
got how excited and happy
you guys were for me that was just it
was the gig of my life
and um everybody over snl could not
have made it easier it was just from the
the second i got over there
till when i left that place um
it was just it was just the greatest
experience i've had so
i will never forget it i will never
forget it and
um i will be watching next week issa rae
is up next and uh i saw a few of the
hosts they got coming up after that
it just keeps getting better so
that is it everybody that is the podcast
i will talk to you
uh i'll check in on you on thursday all
right go [ __ ] yourselves i'll see you
you